( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
MY GUEST TONIGHT AN
ASTROPHYSICIST AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE HAYDEN PLANETARIUM.
HIS NEW SHOW FOR THE NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC CHANNEL IS CALLED
"STAR TALK."
>> THE CLOSER ARE YOU TO A
STRONG SOURCE OF GRAVITY, THE
SLOWER YOUR TIME TICKS RELATIVE
TO PEOPLE YOU LEFT AT HOME.
>> YEAH.
>> AND SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO
COMMIT TO A VISIT OF A PLANET
WHERE TIME IS TICKING MORE
SLOWLY, THEN YOU'VE GOT TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
HOW MUCH MORE SLOWLY IS IT
TICKING?
>> YEAH.
>> AND WHAT ARE THE AGES OF YOUR
KIDS RELATIVE TO YOU WHEN YOU GO
BACK AND --
>> YEAH, WELL, BEFORE I GO DOWN
THAT BRAND, ANNE HATHAWAY'S
CHARACTER HAS A LINE, YOU KNOW,
SHE SAYS "WE'VE GOT TO VIEW TIME
AS A RESOURCE" LIKE OXYGEN.
>> AS A COMMODITY.
>> AND FOOD. EXACTLY.
>> THAT'S A GREAT LINE.
>> AND I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS A
COOL IDEA.
>> Jon: THE BLOND GUY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT NEIL WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
PLEASE WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
YOUNG MAN!
PLEASE.
WHAT AN EXCITING TIME.
>> OH, MAN.
>> Jon: SO NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
>> Jon: WHAT AN EXCITING
TIME TO BE YOU AND AN
ASTROPHYSICIST.
>> YOU'RE LEANING IN HERE.
MAN, OKAY.
>> Jon: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS.
ARE WE GOING TO LIVE ON MARS?
>> AS FAR AS I CAN TELL NO TIME
SOON.
>> Jon: NO TIME SOON.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE MARS IS-- YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE WANT TO GO THERE
AND HANG OUT --
>> Jon: RIGHT. RIGHT.
>> AND YOU HAVE TO
REMIND THEM THAT, LIKE, YOU
CAN'T BREATHE THE AIR. RIGHT?
LITTLE-- LITTLE FACTS -- YOU
KNOW, THE PILGRIMS CAME FROM
EUROPE TO THE NEW WORLD.
>> Jon: YES.
>> WHEN THEY GOT OFF THE
"MAYFLOWER" THEY COULD BREATHE
THE AIR. RIGHT?
LIKE THE TREES-- THE TREES IN
THE NEW WORLD WERE MADE OF WOOD,
JUST LIKE THE TREES THEY BUILT
THEIR SHIPS WITH.
>> Jon: YES.
>> SO THEY COULD REPAIR THEIR
SHIPS AND PEOPLE WERE THERE TO
GREET THEM IN THE NEW WORLD.
IF I GO TO MARS-- NO.
NO.
>> Jon: YOU CAN'T BREATHE.
>> NO, YOU CAN'T BREATHE.
YOU CAN'T REPAIR YOUR SHIP.
>> Jon: THE, THE -- SO WHAT--
WHAT-- WHAT HAS LIT A
FIRE FOR YOU SCIENTIFICALLY
RIGHT NOW?
YOU ALWAYS HAVE A LITTLE
SOMETHING IN YOUR POCKET THAT
GIVES YOU THE PASSION, THE
SPARK.
WHAT IS IT IN THE SCIENCE WORLD
RIGHT NOW THAT'S GOT YOU THERE?
>> I'VE GOT TO SAY IT'S NOT EVEN
ABOUT SCIENCE.
IT'S-- IT'S THE WARMTH-- THE
RISE OF THE WARMTH THAT I SEE IN
THE PUBLIC FOR LEARNING ABOUT
SCIENCE.
>> Jon: OH, REALLY?
>> AND THE EXCITEMENT THAT
BRINGS.
>> Jon: YOU FEEL THE
DIFFERENCE?
>> I FEEL. IT.
OH MAN.
OH
>> Jon: THAT'S INTERESTING.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT'S NOT JUST THIS IS SCIENCE,
LET ME LEARN ABOUT IT.
IT'S THAT THERE IS A CULTURE
THAT THINKS ABOUT SCIENCE AND
LIKES SCIENCE --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> THAT IS RISING
UP IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND IT'S EXEMPLIFIED BY --
LIKE THE GEEKOSPHERE LED THAT.
>> Jon: RIGHT. NOW IS GEEK, IS
GEEK A WORD?
IS THAT SOMETHING I CAN USE OR
ONLY YOU GUYS CAN USE?
IS THAT -- HOW DOES THAT--
>> WELL, I'LL TELL
YOU. IN THE OLD DAYS --
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER THE OLD DAYS.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> IF YOU WERE A GEEK IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> YOU WERE THE ONE WHO
GOT THE WEDGY BY THE
FOOTBALL QUARTERBACK.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> YOU WERE THE ONE
WHO WERE EXPLOITED --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> CALLED YOU FOUR-EYES,
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
AND THEN THE QUARTERBACK LEARNED
THAT THEY NEEDED YOU --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> TO FIX THEIR COMPUTER.
AND THEN THE STOCK VALUE OF
GEEKS ROSE.
THE RICHEST PERSON IN THE WORLD
IS THE PATRON SAINT OF NERDS,
BILL GATES.
SO THE WORLD IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE OF THIS.
BECAUSE WE ONLY ENTER THE FUTURE
ON THE INTELLECTUAL CAPITAL
BROUGHT TO THIS WORLD BY THE
GEEK-O-SPHERE.
( APPLAUSE )
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> Jon: AND I WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON THIS BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY,
YOU'RE A LEARNED MAN.
YOU'RE AN EDUCATED MAN.
YOU'RE A MAN DEALS IN FACT AND
REALITY.
SUPERMAN VERSUS BATMAN.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
YOU KNOW, SO THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION IN THE AUDIENCE --
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: ABOUT WHO WOULD WIN,
SUPERMAN VERSUS BATMAN.
WHO WOULD WIN, SUPERMAN
VERSUS BATMAN?
PERSONALLY, I DON'T EVEN HAVE A
QUESTION-- BATMAN'S JUST A GUY
WITH A NICE BELT.
SUPERMAN IS INVINCIBLE.
HE IS FASTER THAN A SPEEDING
BULLET.
HE CAN FLY.
HE CAN -- I JUST, I DON'T
EVEN SEE IT AS A CONTEST.
>> I WOULD TELL YOU WHAT
IT'S ABOUT.
I WOULD TELL YOU.
I WOULD TELL YOU. OKAY?
WHO DOES BATMAN REPORT TO?
THE MAYOR --
>> Jon: COMMISSIONER
GORDON.
>> YEAH, YEAH. THE
COMMISSIONER --
THE POLICE COMMISSIONER AND
ULTIMATELY THE MAYOR.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> WHO DOES SUPERMAN REPORT TO?
>> Jon: THE GUY IN THE ICE
CASTLE.
>> YEAH, YEAH, RIGHT. SO IT'S NO
ONE WE KNOW.
IT'S NO ONE WE HAVE ANY INSIGHT
INTO.
>> Jon: EXACTLY.
>> HE JUST BEHAVES IN WHATEVER
WAY HE WANTS.
>> Jon: YES.
>> SO AT THE END OF THE DAY WHAT
MIGHT MATTER IS THE PUBLIC
RECEPTION OF THE SUPERHERO AND
SUPERHERO'S CONDUCT.
AND IF BATMAN EXECUTES OUR
WISHES IN THE CITY AND SUPERMAN
DOES WHAT THE HELL HE WANTS,
THAT'S-- THAT-- THAT'S A
CONFLICT.
>> Jon: YOU CANNOT BE A
GUY IN A LEOTARD AND NOT
-- AND JUST BE HUMAN.
LIKE SUPERMAN CAN GET AWAY WITH
IT CAUSE HE'S SUPERMAN.
>> AND THESE ARE BLUE LEOTARDS,
YEAH, PANTYHOSE,
WHATEVER HE'S WEARING --
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: THAT'S RIGHT. BUT IRON
MAN I THINK FIGURED SOMETHING
OUT, WHICH IS THAT I SHOULD WEAR
IRON AND NOT A LEOTARD.
( LAUGHTER )
>> THAT'S RIGHT -- BASIC FACTS.
>> WHEN IS "STAR TALK" ON?
>> OH, THANKS.
IT'S-- IT JUMPED SPECIES TO
TELEVISION.
>> Jon: IT DID.
IT WAS ON THE RADIO. IT WAS A
RADIO SHOW.
>> AND DID YOU KNOW, HE WAS ON
AN ORIGINAL EPISODE OF
"STAR TALK."
>> Jon: THE ORIGINAL "STAR
TALK."
>> AND I FOUND OUT, THAT'S
WHEN I FOUND OUT HE MAJORED
IN CHEMISTRY IN COLLEGE AND THEN
I ASKED THE GEEK QUESTION
WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE ELEMENT?
AND HE SAYS I HAVE A FAVORITE
ELEMENT.
I HAD A POSTER OF IT ON MY WALL.
>> Jon: WHAT'S UP? WHAT'S UP?
>> IT'S CARBON.
>> Jon: BOOM.
>> AND I SAID WHY IS IT CARBON,
AND HE SAID, BECAUSE HE KNEW
THAT CARBON COMBINES WITH ALL
OTHER ELEMENTS ON THE TABLE.
AND HE SAID CARBON IS LIKE THE
SLUT OF THE PERIODIC TABLE OF
ELEMENTS. THAT'S IT!
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: BONDED WITH EVERYBODY.
CARBON IS ALWAYS LIKE-- OH,
SNAP.
WHAT IS THAT, OXYGEN?
GIVE ME TWO OF THOSE BAD BOYS.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT!
THAT'S RIGHT, I MEAN CO2 --
>> Jon: OH --
HYDROGEN.
>> YEAH, GIVE ME FOUR OF THOSE.
CH-4.
YEAH.
>> Jon: I'M GOING TO ESTER THAT
( BLEEP ).
>> SO, SO "STAR TALK" IS ABOUT
GETTING PEOPLE --
>> Jon: YEAH. YEAH.
>> HEWN FROM POP
CULTURE SUCH AS YOURSELF --
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> AND EXPLORING ALL THE
WAYS SCIENCE HAS MATTERED IN
THEIR LIVES.
SO IT REVEALS THE FACT THAT
SCIENCE MANIFESTS EVEN IN OUR
CHERISHED POP CULTURE
INSTITUTIONS.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHAT I
LOVE ABOUT THAT?
THAT TO ME IS THE SLOGAN FOR
YOU. "SCIENCE MATTERS."
I LIKE THAT.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
"STAR TALK" AIRS ON THE
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC
CHANNEL MONDAYS AT 11:00.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON!